brought to you by the PlayStation
experience in Las Vegas take part in all
the announcements panels and early game
previews December 6th and 7th hey guys
and welcome to reality check
now last week on the show I delved into
the psychology of character creation
answering seminole questions like why do
we choose to create ourselves to
actually be about validating our
real-world appearance and when will
games finally include a bunch in slider
and this weekend what I'm creatively
calling part two it's time to
investigating the motivations behind
creating characters who do not resemble
us including playing as different
genders races and also how the
characters we choose to create could
actually be affecting us well some of
the research and our lab on the first
Dragon Age games suggested that
approximately 30% of men play as women
in the game but less than 10% of women
play as men so there's a total as a sex
a similar trivia so why do people do
this what could be the psychology behind
this decision-making we think the reason
is possibly that one of the great things
that games offer is first of all
equality across the sexes it doesn't
matter whether you play as a man or a
woman you have the same abilities the
same strength one of the other reasons
we might choose to play as a member of
the opposite sex is that this gives us
an opportunity to experience things
through the eyes of somebody else
particularly for a man playing as a
woman we may be exposed to some of the
experiences of casual harassment which
women are far more familiar with than
men are similarly if you play as a
member of a stigmatized minority now as
a middle-aged middle-class white man I
have very little experience of prejudice
but if I play as a stigmatized race and
Dragon Age okay it's not the real thing
but I can start to understand perhaps a
little about what it feels like tell me
why we shouldn't kill you now I think
another possible reason why so many men
choose to play as a woman is that if you
play a typical game which may take 30 40
50 hours in total to complete and as a
third person game you're going to spend
an awful lot of time looking at the rear
end of your character it may be that a
man prefer to look at the rear end of a
woman well that last point was certainly
something echoed in the comments on last
week's episode
but what about the sex asymmetry mark
mentioned our women just less up for
trying new experiences in games now that
doesn't sound right to me so perhaps is
something else going on here we think
one of the reasons why so many women
choose to play as women and only a small
minority play as men here's something
that's been termed the Marah phenomenon
this is reflected by lara croft and it's
the idea that when there is a strong
female protagonist when the the woman
can lead the game then this is extremely
attractive to women because this is
something that they're typically denied
in the real world
in fact in movies the summit called the
Bechtel test which is a test of whether
there is a scene in a movie where two
named women talk about anything that
doesn't involve a man most movies fail
the Bechtel test most games pass it
easily regardless of how you choose to
create your character though the key is
that you get to shape and mold them
however you want but what you might not
realize is as well as you shaping them
they might also be able to have an
impact on how you behave in the game if
you give people a for instance
sexualized avatar so an avatar that's
dressed provocatively they will tend to
behave in a slightly more sexualized way
in game the effects of your online
character on you on your sense of self
has been called the Proteus effects
after the Greek god who could take on
many different forms
we are protium as gamers we create many
different forms that we play with and
those forms affect who we are we think
about these different digital selves in
pretty much the same way that we think
about our real physical offline self
that they have their own motivations
their own desires and we're formed of
all of these different cells but you
know that's not the end of it in fact
the character you create could actually
have an impact on your real-world
behavior even after you put the
controller down and turn off the
computer it's undoubtedly the case that
the disorders we take within a game
cross the membrane into our real lives a
lot of the effects that have been
demonstrated very short-term effects
they're not the sorts of effects that
make us go out and commit acts of
violent crime they may increase our
aggression
a very short period of time of course
they may also make us more cooperative
it's almost certainly the case that the
the broadening of our experience that
the experience of of different selves is
more positive than negative so tell me
your experiences with character creation
do you ever play as a different gender
and have you ever caught yourself
behaving in a real-world situation in a
similar way to how your character might
let me know in the comments down below
or by getting in touch with me on
Twitter oh and also I'd love for you
guys to send me pictures of your latest
creations from whatever game you happen
to be playing it's always fun to see the
characters that other people wind up
creating next week I'll be delving into
the sites of cheat BOTS what are they
how do they work and could they be a
real danger
to our beloved hobby I'll see you then
[Music]
you